we've been all enjoyed this man's work
on FX in It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia since 2005 how about that
and now we can all enjoy the new Apple
TV plus series mythic quest Ravens
banquet a fun show starring in part this
man Rob McIlhenny good to see you sir I
am so happy to be here I am pleased that
you are here so your filly through and
through correct it's not just the
television show this is actual real life
that's right I mean I live him I've
lived in Los Angeles now almost as long
as I lived in Philadelphia but but but
my blood is green
born and raised very much okay so if if
if if a pole needed to be greased to
make sure you did not climb it if the
Eagles win the Superbowl that's that
that would be for you we have ways to
get around it I mean you know the grease
and poles they're doing all sorts of
stuff like that you know the mummer's
parade the whole bit you'd you're you're
into all after summer's parades have you
attended well I grew up in South
Philadelphia about a mile away from the
stadiums and second Street is where the
mummer's parade originates and that's
where I grew up so I spent a lot of time
in fact every New Year's from the time I
was a baby
up until 15 or 16 going the mummer's no
kiddin yeah so it's Jason Kelsey showing
up dressed like that for the parade I
mean talking like he knows his audience
when he does something yeah yeah I was
in Philly for the parade was Superbowl
ready what yes of course well I went to
the Super Bowl and then I didn't have a
plan to fly back for the parade but the
fear of missing out was just too too
great the FOMO is too much FOMO was too
much okay and I hopped on that plane and
and and hung out and I actually was
invited to get onto one of the buses
with the players or there was a bus that
was like tailing the players yes and I
thought about it and thought well first
of all it's their celebration not mine I
don't want to be like you know I don't
wanna be in the van no I mean but
absolutely but then I also I realized I
wouldn't be able to spend it this time
with my friends and family the people
that I grew up with watching the Eagles
and so I hopped off the bus and met with
them I think it's 6 a.m. come on yeah
that's
yeah all right so what was it like when
you saw the Philly special live in in
Minnesota I literally just got goose
bumps
I mean just now is that right I just got
goose bumps think just thinking about
that I do that to people just saying the
words Philly and or special put them
together look at what happened I mean
what I as I said I had the pleasure of
being there and and you know as a Philly
fan I remember about halfway through the
game my wife saying you seem so positive
and I'm like I they're going to win she
said I've never ever heard you say that
and I spend most of my time screaming at
the television just by myself I'm gonna
text chain with all my friends from
Philly and it's even hard for me to be
in mixed company watching that because
it just it freaks people out how upset I
yeah and for whatever reason I mean
through the entire game I said we're
gonna win this game
we're gonna win this game we're gonna
win this game is sure enough well I was
watching the game with that guy over
there Chris Brockman who's a die-hard
Patriot fan and that's kind of where the
game went a little bit off the rails
where it looked like maybe this might
actually happen for Philadelphia because
the coach had the colonies to do what
needed to be done it actually worked
it actually surprised New England and
that's that's where as you know what got
real that day pretty well oh yeah
but still down eight two minutes to get
that ball in the air by the way that
ball near the Hail Mary to Gronk playing
yeah I mean I mean still even then that
once once once they had that strip sack
we thought okay that's it's over right I
mean just get it in the end zone it's
over okay they settle for a field goal
to go up eight and I think all right
well and then and then if you remember
people forget this it was fourth down it
was fourth down was the least third and
long I think was fourth down inside
their own 10-yard line
and and I think he hit Gronk for like a
50 or 20 Europe and now they're almost
at midfield in two plays and thank you
by the way you're wiping your brow right
now yes but as if you're reliving the
moment even though you
the Eagles who want it goosebumps have
gone away but my heart is racing and now
it's not because I'm on TV I do TV a lot
it's because I'm reliving that moment
and it's devastating I love it Rob
McElhenney here on the Rich Eisen show
mythic quest Ravens banquet where did
you come up with this concept well we
looked at the other show that's been
going for 15 years that's called it's
always sunny and filled out for that one
yeah and we thought okay if we're gonna
make a new show we have to make sure
that the title is just as ridiculous as
the first one almost incomprehensible
long hard to remember hard to pronounce
and like it can't fit on a poster so we
came up with shopton yeah we asked a
hundred people and and one zero out of a
hundred people liked the title so that's
a good sign for us well no here's the
thing it's like if you are making up a
video game all right
and it's you know a video game if you
will from the medieval times I mean
that's mythic quest is a great name okay
thank you and you actually did create a
fake video game that's real did it
create one it's not quite playable okay
but it's something that we we use in the
show yes and and essentially what they
created is a sandbox for us to navigate
a character through yes so we can shoot
different things but it's not really a
playable game engine okay yeah and so
you play the creative director for this
video game called mythic quest yes and
Ravens banquet is that's the expansion
which is like the that's it's so the
game has been around for a while and
Ravens banquet is essentially like the
the the big update that they're doing
right and each year in fact we're
working on the second season right now
it's called mythic quest : something
else okay so each year will be a new
expansion we come up we can we workshop
that I mean is there a way that we can
come insert our ideas for you if we if
we come close No okay bye yeah I'm just
being honest however I'm happy to what I
do is I walk around and
like I say hey you know what do you
think of you know of February fall
people are like what I'm like great
the more we confuse people that's the
better I like it so whose job was it to
pitch f murray abraham to put his lush
resume of being an act or on the line to
be part of mythic quest ravens banquet
whose job was that that was my gig what
we we had no we had we had no reason to
believe that he would do something like
this but we wrote the character and then
said okay we spoke with our casting
director Jenny McCarthy and she said all
right well who do you have in mind we
said well the prototype we're thinking
would be like f murray abraham so we
want like an F Murray Abraham type yes
and she was like well what about F
Murray Abraham the angel genuine the guy
the real one yes and we were like he'll
never do it she said well I'll set it to
him and see and he called me I mean we
sent it to him he called me the next day
because she's marvelous yeah this is
marvelous
I'll be there in a jiff and he flew out
to he lives in New York he flew out to
LA and I think he had a blast so your
phone did you know he was calling did
you just walking around life and just
say you know yes way they I got a email
saying Murray would like to talk with
you so that's my next question Murray
it's not F no I tried that he was like
it's Marie I know I was just making a
joke that you've heard every day of your
life
so you have actually attempted that
what's up f is that what you yeah yeah
okay I say hey what's happened enough
and he is on the phone and he was like
it's Marie I said yes I okay no I'm
aware I was trying to break the ice it
could not work so is it your job to get
DeVito on board for It's Always Sunny
yes so how did that one that was even
that was even more tenuous because we
had we had only been on the air I think
we only aired seven episodes okay and we
got a call that you know they put us on
in the middle of the night it was like
11 o'clock at night and they didn't
promote it in any way and I got a call
from John Landgraf who
runs the studio silver yeah the best
yeah and he said oh you know nobody
watched your show and I'm like yeah well
you didn't promote it and Oh nicely done
yeah yeah and he said well you know
here's the thing we're gonna pick you up
for season two thank you but we're not
going to promote it because we don't
have a big marketing budget but what
we'd like to do is bring on an actor of
some of some note somebody with some
cachet that can maybe bring some
attention to the to the show and he said
what do you think about Danny DeVito and
I said we love to had a DeVito but we
don't want him on the show because you
know and nothing against Danny it was
just like you you don't know if it's
gonna screw the dynamic you know of the
of the chemistry of the show right and
he said great well then you don't have a
show and we were like okay get Danny
[Laughter]
Danny was I I went to his house and he's
like Danny wants to meet with you I was
like oh I'll go meet with Danny so I
drove over to his house and sat down
he's like so what's the character and we
hadn't talked about what the character
was I was like whoa I got a I got a do
something so I just made something up on
the spot you spit ball Danny DeVito's
character for it's always sunny yes
however it's not exactly what it turned
into but it was it was something that he
responded to but I remember the moment
where we had him
we were sitting I was sitting there at
his table and his daughter Lucy comes in
who's now in her 30s but at the time she
was I don't know in high school and she
goes oh hey Dad
oh hey Oh Rob I love your show and then
walks out and once you have the kids
since he's got the parents that's it
that was it come on that was it now you
had to be sitting there thinking oh she
walked out and then he looked back at me
and I looked back at him and I said I
got you but you plant something like
that you planted it's something whether
this daughter my gosh I don't know yeah
it worked out now we had him here Rob
McElhenney here on the riches Joey Adam
here a few weeks ago and we play
something called celebrity true or false
where we just grab stuff from the
internet or an articles previous and say
is this true or not that he that he
demands or one of his requests is to
a trampoline on set cuz he loves to
trampoline have you ever seen him
trampoline Rob did he say that was true
he did say that was true did he not
Chris he said that is right gets him
into the mood gets the blood go yeah
gets the blood flow I haven't seen him
on a on a trampoline in fact he had a
trampoline I've never seen this before
in his house in LA he had this big
backyard and he had a trampoline built
into the ground so the ones above ground
you see in fact we have one in our house
because the kids love it but you have
like netting around into the quarry okay
so back in the day I remember kids had
those but they didn't have the netting
because it was the 80s and they just
didn't care I guess some regulation
issues I think so so ours has this
netting Danny's was on the ground and I
think that there was this this thought
that maybe you couldn't get hurt by just
flying 50 feet in the air and then
landing directly on the ground but you
could and I remember doing it and and
falling off and Danny laughing
hysterically and I was like I think I
broke my arm and he was just like
cackling on the ground I realize that I
didn't keep put it in there just to get
people to jump on it and laugh and break
their arms and break their arms turned
out was just dislocated so it wasn't
that how did you get okay
look here's another one how'd you get on
Game of Thrones how about one workout
well so the guys that that create a game
of Thrones are good friends of mine and
I actually met them through sunny turned
out they were fans of sunny this is DB
ya Dan Weiss wine and David Benioff okay
yeah so we became really good friends
and I put them on an episode of sunny
and I said okay you know this is a
reciprocal relationship and I think
here's the problem they think because
they've seen every episode of sunny they
think I'm more famous than I am and they
were like it's gonna take people out of
the show and I'm like trust me you guys
have an audience of 10 times what we
have if not more no one's gonna know or
notice me besides the fact that I'm an
actor man like you know put me on your
show yesterday so it was around that
time that Ed Sheeran was on the show do
you remember ed Sheeran talking about
that yeah he's sang and threw people off
okay
I said look there's a
this was happening at the same time they
just aired it and they were taking a
whole bunch of crap from people yeah and
I was like look there's a big difference
between putting an actor in a scene and
putting ed Sheeran who's one of the most
famous musicians in the world yeah doing
like a very extreme push-up like it's
Shino Sinead O'Connor nothing compares
to you and it's like slowly fading in on
him and he's saying in the Cena mug well
yeah by the way you deserve to take crap
for that so they're like okay well we
can't do anything like that for you
because it's gonna take people out so
we'll just shoot an arrow through your
eye and you'll be you know in and out in
15 minutes well I flew over there with a
bunch of my friends from Philly now this
is Northern Ireland and I visited them
two or three times because it's a free
trip to go get an island and hang out on
Game of Thrones so I bring all my
friends from Philly and they were got to
be background in the show which was
great come on
but just like you know people don't
realize how boring those sets and that
experience can actually be so the fact
that I was only there for 15-20 minutes
was was a blessing because we were
drinking so much whiskey you know so how
did you prepare to be shot in the eye
with an arrow I think I drank like an
entire like at least this much jameson
on the way from the airport to the you
can't even tell it's you
yeah well that was that was them they
they said we need to make sure you're
almost indistinguishable from your
character I'm like no one is going to
know who my character is they think I'm
much more famous I know you I'm a fan of
your show
I couldn't I had no idea that was you
it's also like a split second in in real
time it was the it was the it was the
premiere of the final season and I think
like half I got a ton of text that night
but then then a lot of people saying
with Aaron Rodgers - right yeah we
couldn't figure out which one he was I
think he still hasn't confirmed he just
he just confirmed he wasn't the one that
was running really in the entire
Atlantic like he just that was the he
was less upset about not being able to
be distinguished than being
distinguished is somebody running in the
most unathletic actually body on fire
matter well considering he is a mobile
quarterback I mean
right does he move well yeah he moves
well oh yeah no sure does absolutely he
does all right so mythic quest Ravens
banquet has been picked up yes for
season two on Apple TV plus however
season two will be named mythic quest :
something else yes but it won't be
something else
actually in the blank it's what I mean
yeah yeah I know it's just not I know I
need to determine that I have no shot to
give you another no say what you can say
I just won't listen
see I appreciate that that's the second
time Jeff Garlin I try to give him an
idea for curb he just he refused he said
no I haven't even given an idea for curb
you cannot oh yeah did I I guess I can
respect that sort of thing
we we exercise a tremendous amount of
candor okay
in the half-hour television what do you
think before I let you go over your
Eagles and coming up this season what do
you think here this is the beauty of the
off season of really any sport but
specifically football yes they're going
to win the Super Bowl
I mean look let's see what happens let's
see if we can get a couple of D backs
which would be nice and one receiver
that can stay healthy one one Michelle
was insane last year that really wasn't
saying I was insane how DeSean Jackson's
back takes the top of the defense off
and like game wanted game too and now
you're back he's back the whole thing
and then he just never returned all Sean
Jeffery came back and then went out
again I mean you know I've never I've
never seen anything like that and I know
look at injuries a part of the sport but
I've never seen anything like that and
look at they still were able to hey man
yeah the kid who played quarterback in
Houston what Greg Ward right he was
amazing yeah he caught a huge touched on
the put Cena down playoffs yeah
so if we can I mean he's a baller I mean
if he's also the emergency quarterback
oh yeah gosh it's amazing that's that to
me was a story line up the 2019 Eagles
season it was totally nuts
is that going in it's like wow man Falls
isn't there and whence can't stay
healthy and once was the only one who
stayed healthy the whole season yeah
we're talking about the even the
offensive line - yeah the defensive line
went in and out one
was that the constant yeah of health
yeah and it was interesting too because
he still took a lot of criticism and yet
he had statistically his best season now
no you know well maybe because he's
throwing a guy with name tags pretty
much yeah
well we'll see well I I'm I'm got my
fingers crossed for free agency Rob
thanks for coming on the show man I
appreciate it let's do this again any
time Thank You Fran you got absolutely
that's Rob McElhenney check out mythic
quest ravens banquet available right now
on Apple TV plus and Rob McElhenney on
Instagram our McIlhenny on twitter
thanks for coming on man really sure for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under wreck TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app